[Musique]
le motif principal c'est la
commémoration donc du sang versé par les
musulmans pendant la Première Guerre
mondiale mais déjà il y a eu plusieurs
projets de construction de mosquées mais
en fait la première guerre mondiale a
été je dirais le l'accélération du
processus
[Musique]
on a fait un montage juridique qui a
fait que la Grande Mosquée de Paris sont
sièges sociales a été
décrit à la mosquée d'Alger et les
statues de l'association ont été déposés
à la merkema qui est le tribunal
religieux à Alger pourquoi Alger parce
que c'était un département français dans
lequel la loi de 1905 ne s'appliquait
pas
[Musique]
je dirais un clin d'oeil aux mosquées de
l'Andalousie donc c'est vices
l'Alhambra à Grenade et puis de l'autre
côté vous voyez les mosquées à Tlemcen
les mosquées du Maroc les matériaux qui
ont été choisis viennent également de ce
Maghreb et donc c'est un une alchimie
qui a à mon avis voulu ment tout dans ce
type d'architecture en plein Paris
[Musique]